breaking here at four new details
revealed in the case against a former
elected official accused of killing a
reporter thank you for joining us I'm
Kirsten joy and I'm Christian Gossett as
the eight news now investigators
obtained court documents as a criminal
case against Robert Tellis moves forward
a news now investigator Vanessa Murphy
here with what they say
yeah we're learning exactly where Metro
Police say they found evidence at the
home of Robert Tellis as they pieced
this case together these new details
coming from Grand Jury transcripts a big
part of the investigation video from
Neighbors like this Metro detectives say
they found a Ziploc bag with a piece of
a shoe underneath a couch in telus's
living room a bag in his garage with
pieces of a straw hat and a black and
gray duffel bag also in his garage also
in the transcript testimony that DNA
from scissors a positive match after a
grand jury heard details like this
Robert tell us was indicted for murder
he was the Clark County public
administrator review journal
investigative reporter Jeff gearman
exposed problems under his leadership
Telus then lost the Democratic primary
to keep his job Telus is accused of
going to Jeff gearman's home and
stabbing him to death in early September
now another detail also revealed Jeff
gearman's longtime neighbor realized his
garage door was open he noticed
something was wrong and tried reaching
him he eventually went to gearman's home
and found him Telus is expected back in
court tomorrow morning back to you thank
you Vanessa the review journal recently
filed a motion to unseal additional
documents related to that case